jetzt ist so klassisch ein klassisches
brh herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video und leute heute hat der
macher von youtube an drei merkmale
erkennen youtuber starter pack line
youtuber youtuber ein neues video für
euch was bin ich ich bin er ist der
macher von youtube youtube kann sagen
die leute wir beziehen uns mal wieder
auf unsere plattform und zwar machen wir
heute folgendes sebastian wird mir die
lachen also das lachen von
unterschiedlichen youtube an vorspielen
beispielsweise von dach oder so ich
verbinde mir dabei die augen ihr seht
das video wenn ihr mit raten wollt macht
auch die augen zu er spielt das für mich
ab ich schließe die augen hört hin und
probiert zu erraten welcher youtuber da
gerade gelacht hat sozusagen youtuber am
lachen erwarten was dich so laut gehört
wer ist das motto
ich gehe jetzt erstmal ein konferenz-
oder viel erfolg was jetzt erstmal kopf
hatte ich hab die erste stelle völlig
rausgesucht okay es geht los denn 321
jetzt alter was ist das für ein lachen
das ist auf jeden fall ein mann so viel
kann man sagen ist es schwierig doch das
sei viel einfacher da ist viel viel
einfacher
kennedy aus dem video dass wir das für
mich nicht so schwer also ob das ein
richtiger abgabenlast fläche ist
mittendrin hab ich mir stelle genommen
und ich geredet wird ist normal
ja gerne jetzt schon so lange gemacht
haben kam noch mehr
und du bist vom sauerstoff abstand
kannst also ich hab gar kein bild dazu
solche matip geben was er in dem video
da passiert warte ganz kurz die überlege
ob ich schon irgendeine äußerung treffen
kann also ich hab so ein paar nahm also
wo ich muss ja ausschließen würde
dadurch sozusagen junge ist es nicht
vielleicht ist es einer von den
stuttgartern oder so immer keine ahnung
gibt irgendetwas läuft gerade
minecraft in dem video echt ja also rede
ist das nicht
patrick nein bei petrotec mir vorstellen
könnte irgendwann ist ein zwei personen
projekt in minecraft was gibt es für 2
personen projekte ist ein bisschen älter
2015 war das glaube ich war's wie kommst
du denn da drauf ich weiß nicht
vielleicht dass man mir voll hängen
geblieben ja brocken zu haben es
vielleicht nein ich hätte mir noch ein
tipp die personal zwischenzeitlich
aufgehört mit youtube-videos kannst du
irgendjemandem neben der noch schwerer
zu erwarten ist beim nächsten mal okay
aber ich habe ich auch überschätzt weil
ich die stelle so gut kenne aber ich
würde sagen sogar bis zur ist aber ich
geb dir nochmal demnach erwarte von ihm
das klingt so als wäre das irgendwie so
ein blog kann man die und weggetreten ja
die audioqualität ist ein wie upload
weil der kanal wie gesagt nicht mehr
machen will hatte ja richtig
bürgerrechte ja doch die weiteren gegner
auswärts blockiert doch das konnte man
schon erraten das konto hier ist da ein
kopfhörer ist ein bisschen zickig das
haus zu suchen weil natürlich auch
wieder geredet wird
ich versuche es mal wieder eine feste
wird nicht geredet wird es geht los in
jetzt
das lachen ist auch ist auch wieder
minecraft wird es wieder mal klappt es
nicht
simon unerwünschten darauf gehabt aber
ich weiß ich kann gar nicht es ist
wirklich schwer ich kenne aber die lache
total gut alter hatte kommt jetzt zu
verstehen
ja es ist richtig machen aber die ganze
stelle hier für dich okay okay magst
nicht seht ihr die augen verbinden
kopfhörer rein gespannt und diesmal hat
so ein bisschen mehr zeit die also 34
jahr 2000 war total cool
wir haben hier 66 sekunden und und gerät
so sieht man doch als ob das so schnell
dass wir sind mein kopf nicht ganz
sicher ob du das video kannst aber die
person die sollte ich schon kenne oder
ja ich werde es einfach mal und lasse
das mal irgendwie so dass das 14
also bin ich in dem videoband wir haben
so diese bienen basel challenge gemacht
wie böse das richtige betriebe nicht
lachen challenge weiter für gut aber das
lachen ist witzig gemeint ist das echt
lustig dass der da das kenny natürlich
das kennt man
ok wack die lage ist sehr kurz und kennt
damit was anfangen kannst 321 co jetzt
ist so klassisch und klassisch mit der
der der hölle von bettina als nächstes
fertig und es geht weiter jetzt dagegen
wie kann man das so gut erkennbar wie
kommt man das so schnell hätte ich es
nicht erkannt keine ahnung das ist echt
krank alter lassen sind es fast wie eine
stimme eigentlich das ist teilweise zu
lassen und ja zu der lache jetzt muss
ich sagen das ist tatsächlich eine
relativ tragischer fall
es ist nämlich keine lacher von einem
youtuber sondern sind tonaufnahmen von
einem wal der gestaltet ist und luft
dringt das eigentlich auch gar nicht
lustig mache so weiter zu machen oder
gar nicht einmal das ganze würde
[Musik]
das sterben weiter lesen den kommentar
also gar nicht so sehr dass dadurch das
ist okay und dann habe ich den nächsten
finde ich ok mittelrhein dass auf
mallorca die nach 30 minuten
[Musik]
also leute 2013 abi schon bomben content
gemacht vorher leute seht ihr es 790
1219 abonnenten wir stehen so kurz vor
den 800 jahren ihr wisst was zu tun ist
das aber da letzter kommentar von vor
zwei monaten da kann man mal das video
auf jeden fall wieder absetzen weil
deine lachte ließ die idee wenn das mein
kind wäre hätten mich menschen mit dem
grund ruf beschmutzung angezeigt nächste
letzte rache ist das jetzt ein
stuttgarter soll ich dazu etwas sagen
ich weiß nicht mehr sagt nichts ich
sag's das in sceaux dann zieh mal so
leute das war's auch vom heutigen video
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
wenn ihr mit geraten habe wie es bei
euch war cup jahre erwarten habt ihr so
viel verraten will ich habe mich
komplett fertiggemacht natürlich sagen
sie wenn sie beim nächsten video wieder
und auch hier bietet sich auf 100000
super tipps